Marvel fans are about to get a whole lot
more Thor and we mean that literally a
Marvel's 2019 comic-con panel it was
announced that Natalie Portman would
reprise her role as Jane Foster for Thor
love and thunder which will see her
become the new Thor he has her Portman
reacted to the news visibly giddy over
the announcements Portman took to the
whole H stage to share her feelings
about being the next door she walked
across the panel backed by the cheers of
hundreds of Hall H attendees to accept a
prop Mjolnir from director Taika Waititi
clearly Portman is excited about her
character Jane taking over as the first
female Thor and a second iteration of
the god of thunder and the Marvel
Cinematic Universe but she knows what it
takes to be a superhero and the actress
is fully prepared for the same work else
that transformed Tom Holland under pre
lassen for their own super heroic roles
as a Marvel's sdcc presentation Portman
shared two photos of herself on stage
with me or Nia writing that she wants
everyone to remember what she looked
like during the panel so they can
compare it to a physique and Thor love
and thunder Thor love and thunder takes
inspiration from the Mighty Thor comic
series by Jason Aaron and Russell
Dortmund which turns astrophysicist Jane
Foster into a new iteration of the god
of thunder at the start of the series
Jane is battling breast cancer when she
learned she can carry the mystical
hammer and take over for Thor after he
loses his ability to wield it in the
series Jane's use of mio Nia and
transformations into Thor actually
exacerbates the side effects of a cancer
it's unclear how much of the saga for
love and thunder will the tabs but if
they stay true to the comic storyline it
might be a pretty emotional ride it's
also bound to be an action-packed one as
a female Thor possesses all the same
abilities Odinson does as well as
something extra in the Mighty Thor Jane
has an extra keen dominion over me o Nia
and can alter its velocity and
trajectory after she's already thrown it
she can also round the Benham ease with
me o near by sending it swirling around
their bodies the Mighty Thor mastermind
Aaron couldn't be happier that the
female Thor has come into the MCU and is
eager to see how Portman approaches this
new side of Jane Foster he tweeted well
Wow consider me thunderously excited a
Jane Foster Thor storyline I did with a
tower Dortmund
eyes the winner at color and Matt and so
many more talented artists is one of my
proudest moments and comics I can't wait
to see Taika Waititi and Natalie Portman
playing the goddess of thunder to life
whatever your thoughts on Portman
becoming the new thora this
this is huge news for the actress the
last fan saw referring the MCU was in
Thor the dark world after which she and
Thor broke up off-screen Wortman herself
had also seemingly parted ways with a
Marvel movie world after the Thor sequel
telling The Wall Street Journal in 2016
as far as I know I'm done of course we
know now that Portman isn't through the
MCU and she may not be done with Thor
either Marvel hasn't said one way or
another whether Jane and Thor will give
their relationship another shot and love
and thunder but we're betting it's
possible sorry to hear that Jane dumps
you she didn't dump me you know doctors
mutual dumping after all the two are
both worthy of wielding Mjolnir in the
eyes of the Asgardian gods it seems as
if their vote mance was written in the
stars see Natalie Portman's Jane Foster
become the new Thor when Thor love and
thunder his theaters on November 5th
2021 check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more loop of videos
about the MC use phase four are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and to the bail so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]